Now, as I was saying, there
is a beautiful parcel available
right down here by the flat.
I appreciate the offer,
but I have some matters to look after.
Well, I'm confused.
I thought you had completed your mission,
but you're still running around here
with the same little quiver.
It's complicated.
I completed my quest.
He returned to me.
I removed my helmet,
and now I'm in a poor state.
Which is all the more reason
for you to stay here with us.
Where you're from, you may be an apostate,
but here you'd be landed gentry.
The Mandalorians are not just learning
about how to fight.
Oh, you also have to know
how to navigate the galaxy.
That way you'll never be lost.
You are, as its father, a clan
of two.
You have removed your helmet
and you are a mandalorian.
No more.
I'm going to Mandalore
so that I may be forgiven
for my transgressions.
What do we stand for?
Where were you then?
And by the time it becomes big enough
for you to act, it'll be too late.
Hang on, kid.
Welcome back, everyone.
Is Charley The Mandalorian Season
three Release the opening scene with Grogu
using his powers.
There's also another trailer
with a bunch of new footage,
so we'll break it all down.
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes.
It's starting really soon.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'll do a special giveaway
for all my episode videos,
just like I did in previous seasons too.
This scene seems like
it's connected to Mando.
Coming back
to Navarro with Grogu
to meet with Greet Karga,
who's like the new administrator
of the city.
It seems like he's really
cleaned the place up too.
Like it almost looks like
a completely different city,
even though it's the exact same place
that we've been going back to
for the first two seasons.
It sounds like after the events
of season two,
he basically took over
administration of the town
and just slowly started cleaning it up.
And he's trying to convince Mando
to move there permanently.
Mostly because Mando has so many skills
and he wants to be able to use them.
You have this tiny version of Yoda who's
super powerful in the force with you.
Why don't you stay here on Navarro
where we can actually use your talents?
And when we talk about Greef Karga
taking over administration of the town,
remember the previous administrator order
was the client
who was the agent of the empire
or the remnants of the empire.
You probably noticed the funny Easter egg
for him in the background too.
There's a bust of him
sitting against the wall like,
Oh yeah, I remember that guy,
the guy that we killed.
And you have grogu sitting here
during the meeting,
spinning around in the chair
using the force like he's using the force
to just do
childlike, funny things, playing around.
While he's talking to group Karga.
Mando reaches over with his hand
to stop him
from spinning the chair
around in the force.
Then he uses force telekinesis
to pull some space skittles to his mouth.
That's kind of what these look like.
Like red space Skittles.
When Mena says
he appreciates his offer, like,
Oh, it'd be great to live here
and have a chill life.
Just working on smaller problems.
He says he has matters to look after.
That's the whole thing
with what's going on with Bo-Katan
the planet Mandalore regaining his honor,
going back to the planet,
having the darksaber dealing with that.
He's mostly concerned
with regaining his honor
at the beginning of the season,
like fulfilling
the quest that the armor gave to him.
The challenge, all the stuff
with the remnants of the Empire.
Thrawn coming back. Moff Gideon.
He's technically not as worried about that
right at the beginning of the season,
even though that's going on
in the background too.
That will become a bigger deal,
probably in the first couple of episodes
inches that it all starts with him
going back to the planet Mandalore
to reclaim his honor.
We've seen a bunch of footage of him
and bo-katan together.
It seems like he goes to her
before he goes back to the planet
Mandalore because it seems like
a lot of the footage with her in him
or on the planet down in the caves.
It also seems like he goes back
to the planet where the armor has moved
his former cover in these cave system
here, this desert
looking planet before he goes
back to the planet Mandalore.
Every scene that he has with her,
she's always forging something.
Speaking of which, I know everybody's
asking how powerful is Grogu
at the beginning of season three?
Because he's playing around with the force
here in a more confident kind of way.
And you see him in the trailer pushing
around that alien using force telekinesis.
We also see him flashing back again
to order 66, which means he's
just naturally unlocking more
and more of his memories,
remembering more and more of his training
at the Jedi Temple.
I think they're giving him a very Luke
Skywalker Pace kind of arc as Luke
Skywalker's abilities
developed through the original trilogy.
Like by the time
he got to the end of Return of the Jedi,
his powers are much greater
than they were during Empire Strikes Back
and again when he came back
during The Mandalorian Season two.
And Grogu
will just have a much quicker
version of that
because Mandalorian seasons are coming out
way quicker than the original trilogy.
Movies came out with.
The idea at the beginning of season
three is that
he's still slowly
regaining his former levels
of abilities, though, like he's
only about as powerful as he was before.
But the whole idea with force users
like Grogu,
who Luke Skywalker,
pretty much everybody else,
even the Sith Force users,
is that it's all about
their relative potential in the force.
So every time a force user is born,
no matter what race they come from,
they're born with like 100%
of their actual natural ability ages
that over time with training,
they just get better at using those
abilities and connecting to the force.
So, for example, as powerful as Luke
Skywalker gets by the events
of the sequel trilogy,
he was essentially born that powerful.
It just that when he was born,
he didn't know how to use the force,
so he wasn't trying.
Energies took him his whole life
to refine those abilities.
That was why being like Yoda, who's
so innately connected to the force,
just naturally because of his species,
became so much more powerful
because he had 900 plus years
to refine his abilities.
So it's the same idea with Goku.
He'll just continue getting more powerful
as he slowly gets older.
And the same is true for all Jedi.
Just in general,
some just live longer than others.
The whole idea with Jedi
is that as you get
older, like the old men,
old women of the Jedi Order
or the Sith Order even are more powerful
than the younger ones.
It's like the reverse of normal
real world logic,
where as you get older, you get weaker.
When you're a Jedi, you get older,
you get more powerful
because you become more connected
to your abilities in the force.
But you're born
with 100% of that potential.
So we'll probably see Grogu unlocking
more abilities through the season,
Saving Mando a couple of times
with the force and just slowly developing
even new abilities
like learning new things along the way.
I still love the way that Mando refers to
The Jedi is ancient sorcerers.
Like all your ancient sorcery abilities,
you're getting much more powerful now.
I think part of the idea with other
regular mandalorians like Bo-Katan
and her sect of night
owls are just much more use to the Jedi.
Like she worked with Asoka and Skywalker
Obi-Wan Kenobi
during the events of the Clone Wars
in the Rebel series.
So she's much less impressed
by the whole notion of the force.
Speaking of which, you have the whole idea
of the Darksaber, which is a lightsaber.
They just call it the Darksaber.
There's all that stuff
going on in the background.
The whole idea with the Darksaber
is that within the Mandalorian culture,
even on Bo-Katan side of things
and on the armor side of things,
they're like two different sides
of these mandalorian ideals
of what their race should be.
The Darksaber is used
is the right to rule.
It's like a symbol of leadership.
And as long as you win it in combat
from the previous wielder, you're
basically given the throne of Mandalore
the rulership of Mandalore.
Everyone bows in fealty to you
unless they're like a rogue Mandalorian.
Maybe we'll see some of those
during the season,
but the whole idea is that
I think Bo-Katan wants the Darksaber
because she wants to take the planet
mandalore back and restore their people.
It's just that
she has a completely separate idea
of where to take their culture
in the future as opposed to the armor.
But right now,
the only way for her to take the darksaber
the right way
so that the rest of the people,
the other mandalorians will follow her
is if she kills Mando.
He's obviously not going to let her
do that, and he's a better fighter.
There's also this weird sexual tension
going on between the two of them,
even though in every single scene
that you watch with Bo-Katan Kryze
in the Clone Wars in the rebel series
that she's appeared in before,
you really don't get any kind of energy
like that from her.
Like you have. The whole thing was Sateen
and Obi-Wan Kenobi.
That's about as much romance as you see
within the culture of the mandalorians.
Quick reminder, the Duchess as a teen
was the older sister of Bo-Katan Kryze.
If they reference the teen,
it'll probably be on the Obi-Wan Kenobi
series if they do a season two,
but they'll keep it to Obi-Wan Kenobi.
So right now, Bo-Katan is sitting
on the throne of Mandalore.
She thinks of herself
as the leader of their people,
but because she can't get the Darksaber
back,
that's
why she's really pissed off at Mando.
At the beginning of the season.
And it seems like what she's trying to do
is just use him as a finger puppet,
even though obviously he's
not going to let himself be used that way
as a sort of rallying cry
for their people.
Like, okay, I'm not going to kill you
or try to kill you right now in Mando,
but you need to help me rally our people
so we can take back the planet.
So while the scenes of her with Mando
just seems like she's trying
to stay close to him
and use him towards her own ends.
But if you talk about shipping Mando
in Bo-Katan together, like if you see the
two of them standing with Grogu,
you hear like mom and dad in there,
kid with a really legit easy
way for her to gain.
The throne of Mandalore is to get married
to Mando like they as a couple rule
the Mandalorian culture and he just more
the public face of the mandalorians.
And she's the person
who actually does the day to day ruling.
This is one of the few things they haven't
really gotten into with the backstory
behind the Mandalorian Culture is
what their relationships are like.
Like what is a married Mandalorian couple
like in their children,
but in the background of this scene
with the heavy infantrymen.
Jon Favreau's character, Paz Vizsla,
you see a bunch of Mandalorian children
running around
in tiny little beskar armor.
So it seems like
we'll see some Mandalorian families
just talking about the other
new trailer footage they released.
There's a scene of them
riding through the streets here,
which seems like tattooing.
They kind of couple scenes of Grogu
and Mando taking off in the Naboo
Starfighter with Bo-Katan
in her Mandalorian Starfighter,
her ship is completely different.
We saw a preview of that
during season two.
Whatever's going on on this planet,
she's being chased
by a bunch of Tai interceptors.
You see Grogu
wearing his chainmail beskar shirt.
I can't tell you which ships
Mando is shooting down in this action
scene of the asteroids here,
but it just seems like
he's on another mission
and there is an R2.
I think there may be an R5 unit
in the background here, but the ship too.
That's probably the reason why Grogu,
who is riding inside the cockpit with him,
and we get another glorious
looking jetpack scene
with a bunch of the armors
Mandalorians and Mando.
But big reminder season
three Episode one is going to start March
1st and it's eight episodes for season
three, just like previous seasons.
Of course
I'll do videos for all the episodes
just like I did in previous years,
because Ant-Man and the Wasp
Quantumania is coming out this weekend.
My Post-Credits
scene video will post on Friday.
Be sure to go see it as soon as possible.
There's so much stuff to talk about.
And then my full breakdown
Easter eggs for the entire movie
We'll post Saturday morning.
There were a whole bunch of other
big trailers recently.
Everyone click here for that
last Big Mandalorian Season
three trailer video and click here
for my brand new flash trailer
with a whole bunch of Batman in it.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.